okay good morning thanks for joining us
here today my name is Katie Wellman I'm
an assistant professor of the University
of Pennsylvania my lab is interested in
understanding metabolic alterations that
occur in cancer cells as well as
potentially how those alterations could
be exploited therapeutically so one of
our major focuses in the lab right now
is an understanding metabolic control
over the epigenome and that will be the
focus of my presentation today now i do
want to also remind you that if you
should have questions throughout the
presentation please just click on your
Q&A button and type in your question and
then i'll kill me that there are
questions coming in and i'll address all
of those questions then at the end of
the presentation okay so cancer of
course is both a genetic and an
epigenetic disease and in fact it's
actually been recently proposed that
epigenomic disruption should probably
actually be considered as an enabling
characteristic of cancer cells required
for malignant transformation right
alongside genome instability and
mutation and there certainly is a lot of
collaboration between genetic mutations
and epigenomic alterations in driving
tumor initiation and tumor growth okay
so what causes epigenomic disruption in
cancer cells well certainly there are a
lot of mutations actually in epigenetic
in genes including epigenetic regulators
that mediate much of these epigenetic
alterations that can be observed in
cancer cells but it's very likely that
other mechanisms also contribute
including the regulation of cellular
metabolism okay now the idea that
metabolism can regulate the epigenome
really hinges on the idea that different
chromatin modifying enzymes rely on key
intracellular metabolites as cofactors
or donor substrates so for example his
own and DNA methyltransferases use
s-adenosylmethionine or sam as the
methyl group donor jumanji domain
history demethylases or ted proteins
which are implicated in viene de
pollution use alpha keita litter 8 as a
cofactor histone acetyltransferases use
acetyl sorry use Alva cute igloo right
as a cofactor histone acetyltransferases
rely on acetyl co way as a donor
substrate sirtuin deacetylases use nid
as a cofactor oblique net transfer is OG
t which actually came like oscillate
histones relies on UDP and a subtle
glucosamine the end product of the
hexose in a pathway as but don't our
substrate for this reaction so you can
see how there are all of these links
between these core metabolic pathways
metabolites that derived from these
pathways and potential regulation of
these chromatin modifying enzymes but I
think in thinking about this one of the
key points to kind of keep in mind is
well which of these metabolites actually
reach levels at which they're limiting
or regulatory for the activities of
these enzymes and under what conditions
might this occur now we know that in
cancer cells metabolism is extensively
rewired in order to support
macromolecular biosynthesis growth and
proliferation the cinetic rewiring is
typically mediated by oncogenic
activation of signal transduction
pathways and transcription factors for
example the ps3 kinase akt pathway is a
potent regulator of glucose uptake and
glycolytic metabolism whereas oncogenic
mick drives the uptake and metabolism of
both glucose as well as another key
nutrient for cancer cells glutamine so
you can see or you can imagine how with
all of these metabolic alterations going
on cancer cells it seems quite plausible
that the availability of particular
metabolites such as these two points and
modifying enzymes could potentially be
altered and so we've become very
interested in the question of whether
metabolic reprogramming could
potentially old underlie some cancer
cell at the genetic alterations okay so
is the fact that chromatin modifying
enzymes require metabolites actually
meaningful to the biology of the cancer
cell so thinking about this question a
few of the I guess so key questions that
or kind of bearing in mind as we
approach this are well which of these
metabolites actually become limiting or
regulatory for chromatin modifications
how does nutrient availability or aunt
Regina to induce metabolic reprogramming
alter the availability of these
metabolites in cancer cells and then
what does this mean functionally for the
ability of cells to proliferate and for
tumors to grow and is it possible that
some tumor enabling epigenetic
alterations might occur in part as a
consequence of oncogenic metabolic with
programming ok so our lab really has
focused primarily on acetylcholine
metabolism and the regulation of histone
acetylation so obviously if you're going
to a satellite systems you need the
donor substrate acetyl co way within the
nucleocytoplasmic compartment so in
mammalian cells acetyl co way is
compartmentalized into mitochondrial and
nucleus lightest solid pools now outside
the mitochondria there's really two
enzymes that are responsible for co COI
production one is acetyl co a synthetase
which makes a silk away from acetate and
the other is ATP citrate lyase or ACL
which cleaves citrate into acetyl co way
and oxaloacetate and so in order to make
acetyl co way from glucose within the
nucleus cytoplasmic compartment this
really relies on production of citrate
in the TCA cycle and then export of that
sit right out of the mitochondria to the
cytoplasm where it can be cleaved by ACL
to make acetyl co a this acetyl co eight
men can be used phones to support de
novo lipid synthesis it's a it's a
necessary biosynthetic precursor for for
both fatty acid and cholesterol
biosynthesis and it can also be used for
celebration reactions okay so a few
years ago we became interested in the
question of whether the ability of the
cells or loose acetyl co way might be
able to limit its ability to Isetta late
proteins and in particular histones so
just as a reminder i want to point out
that DNA
packaged into chromatin and the
fundamental packing unit of chromatin is
the nucleus own so the nucleosome
consists of about 146 base pairs of DNA
wrapped around a histone octamer with
two copies each of histone h3 h4 h da
and h2b histones contain these
n-terminal tails that extend out from
the nucleosome and are subject to a
number of different post translational
modifications which include a set
elysion methylation phosphorylation and
a number of other types of modifications
that impact on gene expression ability
of cells to repair DNA damage DNA
replication and so on so these have a
number of important functional roles of
settle a shin of histones in general is
associated with the activation of gene
expression okay so is a set elation of
histones actually limited by the ability
of the cell to make acetylcholine so to
address this question we actually did a
very simple experiment we simply
silenced the two enzymes that make
nucleus itís alec acetyl Croix is young
and acs and then looked at global levels
of histone acetylation and so here you
can see that when we silence ACL this
results in very pronounced suppression
of overall levels of histone acetylation
when we finance acs we see some modest
reductions in overall histone
acetylation models and when we silence
both enzymes this result a really
extremely pronounced suppression of
overall histone acetylation levels in
addition if we supplemented acetate
which again is coming in through acs we
can rescue the defect in histone
acetylation in the absence of ACL but
not in the absence of acs which tells us
that it really is the ability of the
cell to produce a pseudo koi that is
dictating these global histone
acetylation levels and so these results
tell us that yes in mammalian cells it
is possible that acetyl co a production
can limit asset elation of histones that
at least under standard culture
conditions that a cancer cell line ECL
is the main source of acetyl co a but
the AC has certainly can substitute if
there is
sufficient levels of its substrate
acetate around okay now in this study we
also found that ACL is present with any
nucleus as well as the cytoplasm now
previously ACL had been thought of as a
cytoplasmic enzyme in large part because
of its major role in lipid synthesis but
we found here both looking at imaging of
egfp tagged ACL that it is present both
in the nucleus and cytoplasm as well as
I subcellular fractionation that ACL as
well as a CS can be found in both
compartments suggesting the possibility
that regulation of nuclear oscillation
events might require a production of
acetyl koi actually with then a nucleus
okay so I've shown you that by basically
getting rid of the elements that make
acetyl co a we can reduce histone
acetylation but if any of this
physiologically relevant so can we see a
nutritional regulation of histone
acetylation and indeed we can so here
you can see these are three different
glioblastoma cell lines we've cultured
this in increasing concentrations of
glucose so this fish here should read 1
24 25 millimolar glucose for being about
a physiologic level of glucose one being
sort of hypoglycemic and 25 being
hyperglycemic I think what you can
appreciate is that there's a very
clear-cut dose-dependent regulation of
histone acetylation and we can see this
really in all of these glioblastoma cell
lines at the examines now this is
occurring under conditions in which
cells are fully viable we do see a
little bit of a slowing of doubling time
when cells are in one millimolar glucose
this is L 1 229 cells these measurements
are on Ellen 229 sales so you see a
little bit of slowing when they're in 1
milliwatt of glucose and between 20 and
25 you're seeing basically proliferation
staying about the same and over this
rage we're also seeing increases
glucose-dependent increases in histone
acetylation which tells us that these
histone acetylation events are not
simply secondary to proliferation now we
do also see that cells begin taking up
more
you mean another key nutrient for cancer
cells when glucose is limited although
as you can see this is not apparently
not sufficient to allow cells the same
histone acetylation under these low
glucose conditions and that's probably
because the glutamine is going to
sustain bioenergetics and viability on
under low glucose conditions now this
glucose-dependent regulation of histone
acetylation does depend on ACL you see
here if we silence ACM we basically lose
this glucose-dependent or severely blunt
the Salukis dependent regulation of
histone acetylation so histone
acetylation is glucose dependent and
this relies on the action of ACM alright
so in order to really better understand
this phenomenon we wanted to know well
what are a co COI levels in the cell how
are they regulated by glucose
availability and are they regulated
really within a range that could
plausibly regularly pistol nação
transferase enzymes and so what we've
done here is to measure by LC mass spec
levels of acetylcholine as well as a
product of the have reaction Commons I
name and we normalize this the cell
volume measurements so that we can get
absolute levels of these metabolites in
the cell and so what you can see is that
under high glucose conditions we're
getting acetylcholine a range of about
six to thirteen micromolar and then
under low glucose conditions it falls
down to about 2 to 3 micro molar so
acetyl co is dynamically regulated by
glucose availability how about co way we
see that this is it really within the
same range in the cell and it tends to
rise under low glucose conditions and
then if we look at the ratio of these
two metabolites you can see that the
ratio of acetyl co a co a is in the
range of about 1.5 to 2 in high glucose
conditions and then falls down well
below 1 under low glucose conditions and
this ratio likely actually is relevant
to regulation of a little transferase
activity because if you look at some of
the camera KD values for acetyl co and
co way for these enzymes for example
taking a human p calf here you can see
it has a KD for acetyl co way of points
explore micromolar and a ki for co a a
point for for michael moore so these are
very similar values and this is true
also for gcn5 and he's the one which is
the homologue onto a yeast home along to
human sep 60 so many of these engines
are subject to product inhibition by co
a and by Muse with similar affinities
suggesting there should be the ratio
that matters to the cell and as I show
you this ratio is dynamically regulated
by glucose availability so in order to
experimentally test this what we've done
is to isolate nuclei from cells incubate
them with defined concentrations of
acetyl coy and co it and then look at
histone acetylation and so what you can
see is that when we give acetylcholine
we see a higher level of histone
acetylation than in the water treated
nuclei if we then put in an increasing
concentration of co a indeed we see a
dose-dependent suppression of Decimus
elevation indicating that indeed it is
ratio these two metabolites within a
nucleus that can regulate basically
overall histone acetylation levels okay
so as you've seen here histone
acetylation is highly sensitive to to
metabolic state of the cell and so a
question that we're very keenly
interested now in the lab is an
understanding whether i'm gagina news
metabolically programming can alter the
cancer cell at the gym in a particular
histone acetylation and this is a very
active area of research of right now in
our lab what i can say is that we know
that ACL has an important role in
regulating tumor growth so for example
if ACL is silence this leads to a
dramatic suppression of cancer cell
proliferation as well as a de Graaff
tumor growth and this has been largely
ascribed to the rule the new role of ACL
and regulating the noble lipid synthesis
but i think it's entirely plausible that
affects on epigenome could also
potentially contribute to this and so
hopefully we'll have some answers to
that in coming year or so okay so now
i'm going to switch gears a little bit
and talk about some of our work looking
at cellular differentiation
and the role of acetyl co a here in a
model system that we're using here
actually is adipocyte differentiation so
this is basically a model or cells grow
as pre adipocyte primer-blast like
preadipocytes you can grow them to
confluence and treat them with a
hormonal cocktail that basically
activates this very well characterized
transcriptional cascade whereby cells
will differentiate over a period of
several days and to adipocytes
accumulating lipid droplets expressing
fast specific genes taking on this round
and morphology and the reason that we
particularly like this model is because
there's a very clear-cut increase in
overall histone acetylation levels that
occurs during differentiation here if
you compare day 0 preadipocytes two
cells four days into differentiation you
can see this global increase in histone
h3 and h4 acetylation and this is
depended on ACL in addition if we
supplement those with acetate we can
rescue his sonís elevation and the
absence of ACL in a dose-dependent
manner indicating that this regulation
my ACL is due to the availability of
acetyl koi okay so this is some very
pronounced change in overall levels of
histone acetylation so we wanted to know
well are we impacting the ability of
themselves to differentiate so one
parameter that's often used to assess
differentiation as the decides is lipid
accumulation and so here we've done
looked at lipid accumulation in these
cells by oil red o sani you can see each
of these lipid droplets stained red here
by oil red o if we look on the level of
the whole plate you can see it's read
throughout indicating robust
differentiation and let that
accumulation in a control cells if we
silence ACL we see much less lipid we
silence acs we see maybe a little bit
left weapon however as I sort of tried
to emphasize throughout this
presentation acetyl co is important
actually for love the Genesis as well as
for a solution so it's not particularly
surprising that we see impaired lipid
accumulation if we silence ACL so we
want to be able to distinguish between
whether we're seeing just the
suppression of lipid Genesis or an
actual suppression of the
differentiation program and so when we
look to gene expression
to our surprise what we actually found
is that overall the alco genic gene
expression program seems to be largely
intact so it didn't take specific genes
like a p2 adiponectin the master driver
of adequate Genesis which is ppargamma
all turned on pretty much normally even
in the absence of ACL although we did
find that certain genes notably glute
for which is the insulin response of
glucose transporter and if episodes are
regulated in an ECL dependent manner so
if we don't have a CL GUI fours
induction during differentiation is
markedly blanton so this observation let
us the question whether perhaps other
similar genes involved in glucose
metabolism could be similarly regulated
and this actually did turn out to be the
case so looking down the glycolytic
pathway here we see that group for
hexokinase phosphofructokinase and
lactate dehydrogenase we're all
suppressed in the absence of ACL in
dibby sites and could be rescued by
acetate indicating that they are being
regulated by the availability of acetyl
co a we've been going back and done
microwave profiling on these cells and
we find that it's about five to ten
percent of the gene expression program
during adipocyte differentiation that
seems to be dependent on ACL and this
tends to be highly enriched for genes
involved in glucose metabolism okay so I
showed you that in cancer cells we are
seeing some glucose-dependent regulation
of histone acetylation is this also true
in the adipocyte system so we do see
that as we increase glucose availability
we also increase look at accumulation
any cells and histone acetylation also
follows so I'll boat fates of acetyl co
way lipids and settle a shin are being
impacted by glucose availability
furthermore if we supplement acetate we
can push histone acetylation up higher
bully and eat dose of glucose so really
the ability of cells to produce the co
COI seems to be a major regulator of
histone cellulation levels so how about
gene expression when we also see that
this follow so the genes that we
identified as ACL dependent also show a
nice
dose-dependent increase in their
expression during differentiation and
this is dependent on a sialic we silence
ACL this regulation is lost and we see
this is true really for each of these
like a lytic enzymes so this suggests
that changes in nutrient availability
are indeed reflected in gene expression
and that a CO CO a actually is an
important mediator of nutrient dependent
gene expression okay so this suggests a
model in which metabolism regulates
histone acetylation and gene expression
and an ACL dependent manner so glucose
comes into the fouls metabolized through
glycolysis to make pyruvate every way
enters in mitochondria is converted to
acetyl koi acetyl koi and convinces with
oxaloacetate to makes it right scituate
can be oxidized in a TCA cycle or can be
exported out of the mitochondria to the
cytoplasm where it can be cleaved by ACL
to make a co co I a tail actually is
present both within the cytoplasm and a
nucleus and the suggested acetylcholine
production is probably occurring in both
of these compartments so osito Quay and
I can be used by shuttle transfers
enzymes to a set away histones and other
proteins and we know this at least
correlates with the regulation of a
subset of genes involved in glucose
metabolism such as food for suggesting
this positive feedback loop whereby
metabolism is regulating the expression
of glucose metabolism genes so of course
there are a lot of questions really that
come out from this study including you
know where where throughout the genome
is histone acetylation being impacted
we've looked at global levels you know
how specific are these effects and are
they correlated with gene expression
what are the mechanisms that underlie
this regulation of gene expression and
does ACL regulate other acetylenes
within nucleus so these are all
questions that we are pursuing right now
and the story that i'm going to tell you
about now really steps from our
observation that ACL plays a role in
regulating another key chromatin
modifying enzyme within the nucleus of
adipocytes and that is DNA
methyltransferase one or dnmt1 okay so
what we observed is that levels of
Mt one actually our support expressing
is expressed in preadipocytes NTN mt one
is downregulated on during
differentiation and this appears to
occur in at least partially an ecl
dependent manner so the suppression of
dnmt1 during differentiation is at least
blunted if we silence ACL and this
appears to occur not at a
transcriptional level since dn.m two and
mrna levels are not higher in the
absence of ACL okay so taking a step
backwards here what is DNA methylation
basically this is the addition of a
methyl group to the five position on the
cytosine ring DNA methylation typically
occurs at cpg dinucleotides indian
promoters i know is associated with gene
silencing okay so DNA methylation can
occur either de novo and this is
typically mediated by dnmt3a and 3b or
it can occur as a me tense function and
this is mediated by the nmt one so dnmt1
actually associate with the replication
machinery at the replication fork and is
responsible for maintaining DNA
methylation patterns during DNA
replication now we hypothesized that
there could very well be a role for
dnmt1 join it at the site
differentiation since at least in the 3d
301 model that we're using there is a
role for DNA replication during
differentiation so basically after cells
are induced to differentiate their
they're both arrested at that time they
actually reenter the cell cycle undergo
about two rounds of cell division then
growth arrest and go towards terminal
differentiation so these properties are
normally thought to be separated in time
so there's this proliferative burst at
the sort of differentiation called
mitotic coronal expansion and then later
on terminal differentiation and so this
looks something like this you're getting
basically a quadrupling of doubling time
sorry upper drooping of cell number
between 12 and 16 hours after reducing
differentiation and so this would
suggest that DNA methylation
patterns either will be diluted out if
the nmt wants not active rule will be
maintained if dnmt1 is active during
this time period okay so dnmt1 levels
are consistent with a potential role
during this mitotic criminal expansion
period so we see looking at the nmt want
mrna levels that they come up by about
24 hours after inducing differentiation
which is during this mitotic criminal
expansion period and then are suppressed
later and differentiation dnmt3a and
three-bean shows sort of different
patterns of regulation if we look at
protein levels we also see dnmt1 coming
up by about 24 hours and then coming
back down again and being further
suppressed later in differentiation even
well below levels that were found in
created the sites so we think there's
really a two-fold regulation of dnmt1
here a transcriptional up and down
regulation and then a later protein
level loss of dnmt1 at the later time
points in differentiation we think that
this is likely relevant in vivo what
we've done is to actually fraction II
Mouse adipose tissue into strong with
vascular and adipocyte fractions and the
preadipocytes are present with a
destroyer vascular fraction and so we
can see the nmt one present in the
stromal vascular fraction but really
undetectable in the adipocyte fraction
indicating that the nmt must also turn
off in adipocytes in vivo okay so does
the empty one functionally regulate
methylation during differentiation so to
address this question we've performed by
soul fight sequencing to examine
methylation at tu lo sai here shown our
group for and ppargamma two genes that
are highly induced during adipocyte
differentiation in fact ppargamma is a
transcription factor that's really the
master regulator of adequate Genesis and
what you can see here so you're looking
each of these individual columns is an
individual CPG at these low side and
then each of these rows then is a
replicate here you see our triplicates
from day 0
day two and a foreign control cells and
then day 0 2 and 4 upon silencing of
dnmt1 and so what they think you can
pretty clearly appreciate here is that
both for glute 4 and 4 ppargamma they're
really in control cells that really are
very minor changes in methylation going
on it looks pretty much the same
throughout these first four days of
differentiation however if dnmt1 is
silence you're seeing a clear reduction
in methylation and this is particularly
apparent between they 0 and 2 of
differentiation which is when this DNA
replication is happening so to suggest
that there and eat is a functional role
for dnmt1 and that it is necessary for
maintaining methylation patterns during
this time period we've also looked at
histone methylation h3k9 die methylation
this was up fabp for and glue for and we
looked at this because the histone
methyltransferase g9a also associates
with the NT want at the replication fork
and plays a role in maintaining histone
h3 canine methylation during replication
as well and indeed we do see that if we
sign with see an empty one we are seeing
reduced levels of histone methylation as
well suggesting that the unity one is
not only having a rolling DNA but also
in histone methylation during this early
period of differentiation all right so
does this mean anything functionally for
those cells in terms of their role
during differentiation so in fact it
does um so actually if we look later on
during differentiation Vsauce be quickly
look pretty normal they differentiate
and have lipid and expressed as specific
genes but where we really see a
difference coming out is an early time
point of differentiation so for example
two days into differentiation control
cells are not yet really accumulating
any lipids but if we sound with cnmt one
now suddenly with the droplets are
starting to appear and they're appearing
very early by about 40 hours after
inducing differentiation we can start to
see these little lipid droplets
appearing whereas it really takes until
about four days until we're seeing this
in the control cells if we look at gene
expression we also
see an early turning on of these fat
specific genes if we select the nmt one
so what we're seeing if we silence the
empty one is really an acceleration of
differentiation suggesting that this
methylation is serving to sort of
restrain the timing of differentiation
and perhaps a temporally separate the
proliferation and that the terminal
differentiation and then just to
reiterate we do see that these cells
actually do more or less maintain their
their function there are you know
adipocyte specific functions even after
the scene a few and silencing we see
they do still undergo mitotic clonal
expansion and they increase in cell
number we see a slight reduction with
the nmt one silencing but they do take
up about the same amount of glucose may
be slightly more pronounced en empty one
although their ability to silent to take
up glucose and response to insulin is
essentially identical any cells so the
phenotype of the differentiated cells
essentially the same although what we're
seeing is an acceleration of the
differentiation process okay so how is a
CL regulating dnmt1 well of course we
initially speculated that it must be
through a set elation I man this would
be in line with the literature there are
previous reports showing the dnmt1 is
accelerated and that in fact it's a
citation is promoting its you pick
relation and produce animal degradation
so it would make perfect sense that if a
CL is controlling the ability of salsa
so delayed dnmt1 then if you sign ones
ACL perhaps it doesn't get a set elated
and it doesn't get too creative but
after spending quite some time looking
into this mechanism we finally came to
the conclusion that it seems that the
acceleration of tnt one is actually
probably not dependent on acetyl kawai
availability in the cell so we saw no
regulation by ACL silencing by glucose
availability or by acetate so we saw it
alternative mechanisms to explain this
now of course another common not going
to regulate protein levels and cells is
through micro RNAs which are involved in
translational repression
and so a search of the literature
revealed you know a number of different
micro are names that have been reported
to regulate dnmt1 either directly or
indirectly and also a number of micro
are names that are known to be induced
during a deficit differentiation and so
we sort of made a list of both of these
and it came up with one that looked
particularly interesting which is near
148a so it is known to be induced
certainly during differentiation and it
also is reported to directly bind to the
three prime utr of dnmt1 and regressive
impress it so important a is induced
during differentiation overtime course
that is similar to when we see the
disappearance of dnmt1 and intriguing
let me see that near 148a induction
during differentiation seems to be
dependent on ECM and it's not that ACL
is regulating all micrornas in a cell
for example mere 1031 is a news
perfectly normally even if we silence
ACM so we're seeing a specific
regulation of this particular Michael on
entering differentiation we can also at
least partially rescue known for you the
expression by acetate indicating its
acetyl koi dependent regulation okay so
what happens if we ectopic we express
near 148a and at different sites so if
we do this we can see that levels of
dnmt1 are suppressed as expected and
this was particularly apparent at phase
1 and 2 of differentiation which is
really on that critical time point for
dnmt1 action and in addition we also see
that your own 40-day expression
basically recapitulates the phenotype
that we saw with silencing dnmt1 and
then we see an acceleration of
differentiation so we see early love
accumulation as well as early in the
induction of fact specific genes ok so
this suggested to us something very
interesting about this time course so
normally these processes of this
proliferation during early
differentiation and then differentiation
a terminal differentiation with lipid
accumulation
um and adipocyte specific gene
expression normally these are
temporarily separated processes now
clearly we are seeing that you know by
forty or forty eight hours after
inducing differentiation we're getting
lipid droplets which suggests that these
could potentially be overlapping or
occurring at the same time so we wanted
to know whether this was happening in
the same cells or whether they were
happening sort of side by side whereas
some cells were proliferating and then
arresting and differentiation
differentiating whereas other cells
might be you know beginning to
differentiate after earlier progressed
so we wanted to know ourselves dividing
and differentiating at the same time and
so to address this we've actually filmed
these cells live and here you see just
some screenshots from this and here so
here you for example you see one cell
each of these little black dots is a
lipid droplet if you follow the cell you
can see it divided into two similarly
here you see another cell that has these
lipid droplets and follow this red arrow
here you can see it divided into two and
we found this numerous examples of this
throughout the plate and so we're quite
convinced that actually the lipid
droplet contained cells can be observed
to divide upon expression of mere 148a
okay so why would a cell have this
mechanism as I've already told you these
cells ultimately differentiate normally
so so why would you need to have its
mechanism to sort of temporarily
separate these two processes um well we
don't completely know the answer to this
but what we speculate is that we know
that in vivo precursor cells actually do
express ppargamma which is the master
regulator of alba genesis and is both
necessary and sufficient for adipocyte
differentiation now presumably in vivo
these cells remain as precursor cells
until they receive an appropriate cue to
differentiate so it's possible that
maintaining high DNA methylation levels
will prevent these cells from you know
undergoing spontaneous or inappropriate
differentiation and so receive an
appropriate cute and I think that this
interpretation is supported actually by
looking at classic studies from Taylor
and Jones back in the 1970s so what was
done in this experiment so this
experiment use of the sign como cell
lines uh10 teanna how cells and what
they did was to treat these cells with
DMT inhibitors like 58 either side 18
for a short period of time and then you
know wash it wash it out and allow
themselves to sit there on the plate for
a couple of weeks and what they found is
that they actually got pockets of
spontaneous differentiation so it dip
the sides to myotubes so i think again
this fully supports the notion that DNA
methylation is sort of serving as a
check to tamp down on you know
spontaneous differentiation in cells
that are already sort of predisposed to
go along a certain route but of course
this does require some illegal
validation to know what this model is
indeed correct okay so micrornas as you
may well know typically operate for
regulating a network of genes rather
than just one gene and so I've shown you
that but we can get more or less of
similar differentiation phenotype later
silencing of dnmt1 which basically gets
rid of the ante one or by expressing
your 148a which sort of reduces the ante
when levels but not to the extent that
the NC 1 silencing does so this
suggested to us that normal for da day
likely is operating through other
targets as well from a differentiation
and indeed if we do dmt one silencing
and no avoiding a expression
simultaneously we do see additive
effects on differentiation so we do
think that there are other targets of
mere 140 day that are relevant for
differentiation but we don't yet know
what those targets are okay so then we
wanted to know whether your 148a might
be able to restore differentiation and a
model of hypermethylation mediated
differentiation block okay so bear with
me for a moment while I explain the
model system that we're using here so as
you may know mutations in
isocitrate dehydrogenase wanted to occur
relatively frequently and certain types
of cancers including leukemias and glue
and I gliomas and what happens with
these mutant enzymes is that instead of
tearing out there on normal activity
which is to convert isocitrate into
alpha keita glittering the mutant enzyme
now converts alpha-ketoglutarate into a
metabolite called two hydroxy glittery
which is the term in uncle metabolites
and so basically the idea here is that
two hydroxy butyrate actually can
compete with alpha ketoglutarate from
binding to certain enzymes that require
alpha ketoglutarate including jumanji
domain histidine methylases and test
family 5-methylcytosine hydroxylases
essentially resulting in a
hypermethylation phenotype in tumors
that Harbor these mutations and so many
of these tumors with these mutations
displays sort of a differentiation for
walk in their phenotype and so in a
paper that came out last year in nature
from Craig Thompson flab the rule of
mutant i th in regulating
differentiation processes was explored
and one of the model systems that they
used to explore this was a dip a site
differentiation so in this experiment
Newton idh was expressed in 3d 301
adipocytes and the cells differentiated
and what you can see is that those
basically leads to a differentiation
walk in cells with expressing this
mutant enzyme this can be recapitulated
by simply providing the cells with two
hydroxy butyrate indicating that this
mechanism is likely the case that two
hydroxy bluray is interfering with these
alpha beautiful rates and enzymes to
repress the crunchy asian and what is
observed here in terms of histone
methylation is that when an ID HM unions
are expressed repressive histone marks
like h3k9 diet rheinmetall are elevated
and this occurs throughout
differentiation so normally we see sort
of this down regulation of histone
methylation during
differentiation alongside the system of
setting up regulation and with
expression of the me tonight eh enzymes
we see that that now these cells
maintain high methylation of histones so
the suggests that demethylation of
histones might be important for a dip
site differentiation and this has been
sort of confirmed here by silencing KDM
for sia histone demethylase and this
again results in hyper histone
methylation and a block and
differentiation so demethylation of
histone seems to be important for
differentiation ok so we hypothesize
that if mere 148a acts by inhibiting
methylation reactions by regulating as a
good bien mt1 and potentially other
targets it might be able to reverse
Newton idh mediated suppression of
differentiation so it goes like this I
nature tations resulting two hydroxy
butyrate production inhibition of
histone methylation resulting in
hypermethylation inhibition
differentiation so near 148a can
suppress the nmt one other targets might
just be able to impair methylation and
reverse this hypermethylation and
inhibition of differentiation okay so
this actually turned out to work to our
mother to our surprise and so what you
can see here is that when we express the
meat nine th enzymes in these cells
differentiation is blocked and if we put
a mere one for unity we can at least
partially restored differentiation as
read out both by lipid accumulation and
fafsa cific gene expression we also do
see a suppression of the
hypermethylation observed with me
tonight eh as well now i can't tell you
whether mera 148 plays any role
particularly in idh mutant tumors I
think that's an intriguing question
potentially to explore on the future in
this in a study we've really used it as
a mechanism to propose to approve the
role of young for a day and the nmt one
during differentiation but a search of
the literature reveals some quite
interesting information about near 148a
as i've shown here it does seem to play
a role in promoting adequate Genesis but
looking into the literature also has
been reported to play roles and my
Genesis and osteoclastogenesis and no
one for t-day also is reported to be
suppressed and various types of cancer
including colorectal breast pancreatic
and liver cancer and interestingly in
this study that was published in JC I
earlier this year looking at
hepatocellular carcinoma the restoration
of me over for tea AAA to these tumors
actually could reverse epithelial to
mesenchymal transition or suppress it so
again suggesting that Marilyn 48a might
be serving to maintain tumors and more
on D differentiated state so I think
understandable known for a day in cancer
biology will be very intriguing moving
forward okay so in summary I've shown
you that Co Co way to Co a levels are
dynamically regulated by glucose and
play a role in regulating total histone
acetylation levels we know that the
nuclear mahtab the nuclear ratio of
these metabolites can impact on global
levels to histone acetylation I've shown
you that dnmt1 is important for
maintaining DNA methylation patterns
during early advil genesis during this
mitotic normal expansion period and that
silencing of dnmt1 seems to accelerate
the induction of a dip of site specific
genes and lipid accumulation the NT 1
levels are regulated by ACL this appears
to occur through a surprising mechanism
not through a set elation as we had
originally suspected but rather through
regulation of this micro RNA 148a and we
can bike topically expressing their 148a
we can suppress the nmt one and
accelerate out of the genesis we also
find that hypermethylation can suppress
epigenesis and this can be partially
restored by expression on your 140 day
we see a reversion of the hyper histone
methylation levels and restoration at
least a partial restoration of
differentiation so so there is
suggestion literature that normal for
today may be a general promoter of
differentiation possibly through
manipulation of epigenetics but really
more study will be necessary to bully
nail this down
um so with that I'll conclude my talk
today I want to say a special thanks to
my lab members the work on acetyl co way
that I showed you was done by joyce lee
working with and Blair's lab two for the
mass spec analysis for the dnmt1 story
this was actually done by two previous
technicians in a lot of tatiana londono
genteel and pete Lozado we also had
important collaborations with craig
thompson flab so ciao who actually did
the experiments with the idh mutant
tumors and Scott a legend Jack gave us a
lot of important advice about micro RNAs
Eric witty helped us make the movie
within your own 40 a day expressing
cells and also thank you to my funding
sources and I also do want to remind you
that if you would like to obtain
continuing education credits you need to
go to this website right here and with
that it looks like there's maybe
questions so I'll take a look at what
the questions are let's see okay so it
says have you tried using a small
molecule inhibitor of histone
acetylation and then checked on the
expression of molecules like glue for
this is coming in from IIT which i think
is the Indian Institute for technology
so to answer this question we have tried
using some actually what we've done is
try an inhibiting HDX but we get very
variable responses depending on the HVAC
inhibitors that we use so what we find
is that different h dec inhibitors seem
to have various seems to do various
things to differentiation it's not
consistent across different HD
inhibitors and so it's hard to draw a
conclusion specifically about that we
haven't actually used hat inhibitors um
during the adipocyte differentiation
so that's what I think that's a very
interesting question we have used ACL
inhibitors and we can recapitulate the
effects that we see with ACL knockdown
um but I think you know you raise a good
point that using some hat and killers
would we would expect could help us to
kneel down which of those hats might be
important and we have done that using SI
RNA and so we do think there are
specific of that so particular hats that
are probably regulating these effects
okay and then now we have another
question coming in from UHS and this
question is should cancer patients
severely limit their uptake of lipids
and glucose so that's a very good
question so in terms of glucose I would
say I think it's unlikely to have a
major impact as your body has mechanisms
to tightly regulate like glucose
concentrations so I think that you're
unlikely to actually regulate the
ability of cancer cells that take up
glucose by limiting glucose availability
in terms of lipids there there is some
data out there that that would suggest
that the certain types of lipids that
you eat might be actually relevant to
growth with cancer cells and then
actually perhaps that cancer cells at
least certain types of cancer cells do a
lot of scavenging of lipids from the
extracellular environment and so the
lipids that you are in your diet may may
impact the growth of cancer cells and
actually might be most beneficial sort
of although the it may not be the best
burger heart it may be better to kill
your cancer cells eat higher levels of
saturated fatty acids which could alter
membrane fluidity and so on but these
are topics that really require further
study to know whether patients should
actually be advised to do manipulations
like that
okay another question coming in here
from baylor college of medicine have you
looked at the levels of h3k4 methylation
which have been studied to be in
directly correlated to h3k9
trimethylation that's a good question we
actually have not looked at that but
it's certainly something that we want to
do is get a more overall view of how the
interplay of these different
modifications are being regulated when
we manipulate acetyl co availability but
we haven't actually looked at that yet
okay so that looks like there's no
further questions right now so we'll go
ahead and end the presentation so thanks
everyone for coming today oh there is
one more coming in